et on va plus loin avec annie va grand
reporter de guerre indépendante bonjour
anne bonjour je rappelle que vous et
tire en ukraine il ya un peu plus d'un
mois et demi merci d'être avec nous
aurait bientôt et vous avez passé un
mois sur place gauthier rybinski et
également avec nous la rédaction de
france 24 jean gauthier jo ils le
réclament des armes une fois de plus
volodymyr zelensky demande aux
occidentaux d'aider l'armée ukrainienne
à défendre son territoire face à la
russie à défaut d'une intervention
militaire c'est d'une aide matérielle
que le président ukrainien appelle de
ses voeux et coûté
une partie des missiles a été abattu
mais seulement une partie nous avons
besoin d'une défense aérienne puissante
moderne pleinement efficace et qui
puisse assurer une protection complète
contre ces missiles nous en parlons tous
les jours avec nos partenaires
volodymyr zelensky qui s'adressait par
visioconférence aux chefs d'état des
pays du g7 réunis en sommet en bavière
alors que sa capitale qui est venait
d'être frappé hier par des missiles
russes pour la première fois depuis des
semaines une autre ville du coeur du
pays créé men show qu'elle depuis vu un
centre commercial touché par une frappe
alors qu'un millier de personnes se
trouvaient à l'intérieur on parle d'au
moins dix morts et d'une quarantaine de
blessés bilan provisoire dans un
bâtiment où un incendie s'est depuis
déclaré et puis rare qui frappe
également frappé à nouveau quatre morts
et 19 blessés dans la deuxième ville
d'ukraine ces attaques elle montre à
quel point l'ukraine reste vulnérable au
delà des limites du dombass avec bien
sûr la guerre continue je crois qu'il
faut cesser de de se dire peut-être pour
pour ne plus avoir peur que justement
venir poutine a va obtenir ce qu'il
comptait obtenir puisque c'était pas
kiev ça sera le dans de basses et c'est
la guerre continue on en a eu la preuve
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune raison je ne
vois pas pourquoi les missiles cesserait
de pleuvoir ailleurs que là où on les
attend finalement c'est simple principe
de la guerre je vous rappelle que ce
sont deux belligérants l'un contre
l'autre donc ils ne se font pas du bien
kremeniouk j'y suis passé c'est juste à
côté d'eux ni pro ni procès de grandes
villes d'un gros europe du sud de
l'ukraine à accra menchu qu'il se passe
rien il n'y a pas eu jusqu'à présent
aucun rien du tout donc là c'est
visiblement de cibles militaires en tout
cas comme je ne sais pas nous ne savons
pas vous et moi si celle-ci billy a
véritablement ces cibles sont secrètes
ensuite on nous le résultat le résultat
aujourd'hui en tout cas c'est que
c'était sur un centre commercial qui
évidemment comme les partis il ya des
parties de l'ukraine énormément de
partie de l'ukraine dans lesquelles les
gens vivent essaye de vivre normalement
en allant faire leurs courses etc
c'était le cas dans ce centre commercial
donc je pense que le bilan
malheureusement va augmenter gauthier
davantage d'armes lourdes pour permettre
aux ukrainiens d'être à parité avec les
russes 1 voilà ce que réclame volodymyr
zelensky est ce possible un voeu pieux
d'être à parité avec les russes ça veut
rien dire la parité on a vu des conflits
asymétriques ou ceux qui étaient les
plus faibles pouvait dominer même
momentanément les ce qui était le mieux
équipé on a bien vu que l'armée russe
contrairement à ce qu'elle prétend être
n'est pas une armée d'infanterie elle
est une arme et d'artillerie les hauts
niveaux de l'infanterie sa pêche sa
pêche beaucoup et que donc si les
ukrainiens ont un matériel beaucoup plus
moderne car le matériel de l'armée russe
quoi qu'on en dise est relativement
obsolète pas dans le domaine des
missiles balistiques mais dans le
domaine de l'équipement d'art dire à ce
moment là on peut assister à la même
chose que ce à quoi on a assisté au
début de cette guerre c'est à dire au
moins une façon de contenir la poussée
l'armée russe ce qui n'a pas pu être le
cas par exemple dans le dans le pour la
ville de ciré lô donetsk qui a été
véritablement encerclé et que les
défenseurs ukrainiens n'ont pas pu tenir
mais tout ça on le voit à chaque fois
d'ailleurs à chaque fois il y a un
retard dans la livraison d'armes à
l'ukraine et un certain nombre de choses
finissent par arriver là c'est du
matériel allemand qui aurait été très
très utile dans la défense de ses
valeurs donetsk il n'y a pas forcément
l'idée d'une victoire ukrainienne mais
déjà embourbés l'armée russe comme ça a
été le cas au tour de kiev et bien il y
a quelque chose à gagner à partir du
moment où on considère que les
négociations ne sont pas possible dans
l'immédiat en tout cas boris johnson lui
vaut croire que les ukrainiens ont
encore les moyens de redresser la
situation il l'a dit lors d'un tête à
tête avec emmanuel macron à qui il
reprochait justement de pousser pour des
négociations immédiates écouter le
toujours au g7 il n'y a pas d'accord que
le président zelaya qui puisse vraiment
conclure que nous habitue donc dans ces
circonstances g7 les soutiens de
l'ukraine dans le monde entier doivent
continuer à aider les ukrainiens à
reconstruire leur économie à produire
leurs céréales à les exporter et bien
sûr nous devons les aider à se protéger
et c'est ce que nous allons continuer à
faire comme continue c'est un propice à
des négociations la situation actuelle
elle n'y va pas ça on le dit on le
répète depuis longtemps n'a pas besoin
que brunson nous le rappelle moi ce qui
me choque un peu dans ce que dit boris
johnson c'est que il a l'air de dire que
justement de dire emmanuel macron qui
lui quand même et fin en ta faveur d'une
fin ultime par des négociations que
négocier maintenant ça voudrait dire
prolonger l'instabilité mondiale ça
c'est quelque chose que moi je trouve
incompréhensible parce que est ce que la
guerre elle-même ne prolonge pas on en
elle-même la stabilité mondiale comment
peut-on dire que des négociations de
paix prolongerait la stabilité mondiale
donc il ya visiblement là un paradoxe et
je dire que zelensky aussi ce matin a
dit en même temps qu'il a dit vous
l'avez rappelé qu'il voulait évidemment
des armes il le dit le répète mais il a
dit aussi qu'il fallait que il faudrait
que qu il pensait que la guerre serait
achevée à la fin de l'année et en même
temps ils souhaitent une intensification
des sanctions là c'est aussi ça paraît
pas des vins par donc je ne vois pas
comment on peut intensifier les
sanctions est donc prolongé cette guerre
est en même temps décrété qu'elle sera
terminée à la fin de l'année jeune je ne
sais pas on comprend pas gauthier fermer
la porte à des négociations est ce
vraiment le rose des grandes puissances
qui se veulent responsable at il pas un
risque à entretenir les ukrainiens dans
l'espoir de victoire future au prix du
dialogue ça rejoint la question
précédente et la jda direction total des
accords arikan c'est à dire que si vous
partez du principe que vous donnez à
vladimir poutine se trouve être un autre
dictateur la possibilité au fond de
tirer le bilan de cette affaire en
disant je m'en sors bien je n'en sors
plutôt bien là la déstabilisation future
est encore là et toutes les erreurs des
autres chefs de l'état de l'occident
hormis boris johnson l'on peut en parler
après c'est de considérer que tout sera
récupérable le mode de dialogue le mode
de pensée le mode de commerce comme
avant avec vladimir poutine et qu'au
fond cette guerre en ukraine sera une
très mauvaise parenthèse mais qu'on
n'oubliera les ukrainiens ne sont pas
prêts à oublier ils ne peuvent pas
oublier ce qui a été fait par les
soldats russes et quand boris johnson
affirme que sa thèse c'est vrai qu'un
chef d'état européen ne peut pas se
substituer aux eaux avait à hélène ski
ou à aux autres protagonistes
d'ailleurs c'est ce que souligne
emmanuel macron il dit je ne veux pas me
substituer aux ukrainiens de sorte que
s'il y avait un échec on pourrait le
rendre responsable mais il n'a pas tort
johnson il n'a pas tort sur le fond
parce qu'il est impossible pour les
nuques les ukrainiens aujourd'hui de
négocier quoi que ce soit avec le
couteau sous la gorge qu'ils ont avec la
séparation du donbass et les exactions
que même des soldats russes et toute
négociation aujourd'hui serait une forme
de pattes excuses mais une manière de
passer par pertes et profits on dirait
bron c'est la guerre un bilingue et
riespach toujours des atrocités non je
pense que les ukrainiens ne veulent pas
ça et pour une seule raison je
m'arrêterai là parce que volodymyr nm ce
qui est en train de réhabiliter la force
le politique le volontarisme là vous
avez des gens en occident comme nous
disons la bonne géopolitique c'est de
dire on va retrouver le dialogue avec
poutine on va recommencer à faire du
commerce non vous avez quelqu'un qui dit
je ne tolère pas ça je suis homme
politique et j'avance pour exiger des
choses qui paraissent invraisemblables
inatteignable anne nivat la morale doit
guider en ce moment les dirigeants
je ne suis pas d'accord est ce qui vient
d'être dit mais je pense que c'est là
justement tout le fond du débat le fond
du problème est que c'est intéressant
d'en débattre de toute façon je ne pense
pas comme vous que tout va redevenir
comme près comme avant et je ne pense
pas qu emmanuel macron le pense mais je
pense que la russie va continuer à
exister et que ce soit vladmir poutine
au pouvoir ou pas vladimir poutine au
pouvoir il n'y aura pas un changement
radical de politique en russie donc de
toute façon ce qui est en train de se
passer depuis le 24 février 2022 porte à
conséquence a des conséquences
gravissimes effectivement nous ne sommes
plus dans le même monde nous sommes en
guerre il ya une guerre en route et il
va bien falloir à un moment donné quand
même penser à l'arrêter ou alors est ce
qu'on va continuer à vivre tous en
guerre avec une guerre une menace qui va
être encore plus grande et une menace
atomique je ne sais pas ce n'est pas à
nous de répondre nous sommes que des
observateurs mais il y a parfois une
tendance à aller vers le jusqu'au
boutisme et on ne sait pas jusqu'au bout
justement ça peut aller avec une
différence une fois de plus mais on l'a
déjà dit entre les états unis et
l'europe les etats-unis n'ayant pas les
mêmes conséquences à tirer de ce conflit
que nous il ya un intérêt voilà où en
tout cas un devoir même à essayer
d'arrêter par tous les moyens possibles
ce qui est en train de se passer le plus
vite possible bien sûr oui pas forcément
le plus vite possible jusqu'au creux
malgré un désaccord pardon mais d'une
certaine façon il une différence entre
le réalisme qui consiste à dire voilà
quelle est la situation est évidemment
c'est indispensable par la suite je ne
porte vous anne mais vous avez quantité
d'experts et d'hommes politiques qui
considèrent au fond le réalisme comme
une forme de conformisme en disant c est
comme ça et puis c'est immuable et puis
il n'ya qu'à faire à considérer cette
chose et à vivre avec et puis à limiter
les dégâts
il ya une question qui découlent de ces
lacs est celle de savoir s'il faut
continuer à vivre justement avec ce
genre de choses comme on dit la russie
ne déménagera pas c'est le mode macro
mais ce sont des tautologies qu'ils nous
foutent par exemple dans l'embarras dans
la mouise parce que quel est le vrai
problème c'est la présence à la tête de
la russie d'un dictateur comme boutines
s'il n'y avait pas de dictateur vous
croyez que la russie aurait besoin où on
aurait besoin de s'inventer de fantasmer
sur des menaces à sa frontière non si
elle était démocratique elle n'aurait
pas imaginé ça et donc dire si vous
voulez que les choses vont reprendre
avec poutine ça veut dire tout
simplement considéré comme immuable et
comme intrinsèque à la dictature de
poutine le fait que bien de temps en
temps il fallait passer par un conflit
patate j'exagère c'est un peu ça
particulièrement meurtriers et puis on
passera
oui enfin moi je pense que il ya aussi
une des questions qui montrent justement
que le monde le monde a changé c'est que
nous sommes maintenant dans un monde qui
fait la guerre différemment toutes les
guerres que j'ai couvert précédemment
salir l'irak l'afghanistan la syrie la
turquie ça ne se reproduit plus comme ça
aujourd'hui puisque tout est connu en
direct et que nous avons des pays et des
leaders de ces pays de ce pays agressé
comme l'ukraine qui aujourd'hui en
tirent parti et il a raison en justement
en ayant cette transparence en demandant
des armes etc et le fait que nous
occidentaux n'ayant pas été prêt n'ayant
pas souhaité aller nous battre sur le
terrain en ukraine nous avons décidé de
faire la guerre autrement donc bien sûr
les conséquences sont autres et elles
sont pour tout le monde autre pour toute
notre planète au delà l'ukraine
effectivement la menace est encore
présent que la russie pour ses voisins
pouces l'otan a renforcé sa présence
dans ces pays frontaliers ou proches de
la russie écoutez
nous allons renforcer nos troupes sur le
flanc oriental de l'alliance
nous allons transformer la force de
réaction de l'otan et augmenter le
nombre de nos forces à haut niveau de
préparation pour le porter bien au
dessus de 300 milles
une présence bienvenue ou l'assurance de
troubles futur avec la russie une
présence bienvenu on vient d'en parler
mais là on montre nos muscles mais on
reste à nos frontières donc tout ça
c'est de la rhétorique plus que de la
rhétorique puisqu'on même des milliers
d'hommes qui vont qui vont être sur
place bien sûr mais là rien de nouveau
sous le soleil et gauthier par l'aide de
cette entièrement de ce nouveau monde
l'otan n'est ce pas la quintessence même
de l'ancien monde c'est à dire et c'est
emmanuel macron qui disait lui même
qu'elle était en état de mort cérébrale
en décembre 21 donc est ce qu'on n'est
pas justement au moment où le ce qui se
passe sur notre planète nous obligerait
à réfléchir à de nouvelles alliances à
de nouvelles complicités à 2 à 2 à de
nouvelles amitiés et inimitiés et pas
forcément celle de l'otan qui n'a plus
l'air de correspondre véritablement à ce
qu'est le monde aujourd'hui on voit
quand même le nombre de personnes qui
sont non alignés dans ce conflit entre
l'ukraine et la russie tous ceux qui ne
veulent pas prendre parti ne serait ce
que le premier ministre de l'inde qui
était invitée aujourd'hui oui qui fait
partie de ceux et ils sont nombreux qui
ne sont ni pro russe ni anti russe qui
ne veulent pas considérer vladimir
poutine comme un paria c'est à dire ils
n'ont pas il ya des pays dans le monde
qu'ils n'ont pas qu'ils ne possèdent pas
la même vision du monde que nous autres
occidentaux que les sept pays les plus
industrialisés au monde qui sont soumis
quand même je trouve à rude épreuve
pendant cette cette guerre et les légers
cette le montre c'est à dire malgré
notre puissance nous avons été
incapables nous les pays du g7
d'empêcher cette guerre tenir compte de
la limite y compris durs à convaincre
les autres pays qu'une menace existe
elle est à nos portes et il faut vivre
avec dorénavant en europe le risque
qu'une guerre se déclenche sur le
continent européen je parle du continent
pas la russie évidemment fait partie
mais en tout cas dans l'espace politique
de l'union européenne non c'est pas
obligé là aussi c'est le c'est l'aspect
c'est le nationalisme qui était l'oeuvre
et c'est pour ça que quand on disait
qu'il y ait des non-alignés je trouve
vous pourrez faire le compte mais que
parmi ces non-alignés y en a beaucoup
qui prennent cette posture pour dire
qu'ils sont favorables à poutine ou
presque c'est à dire qu'il y a une façon
de se présenter comme étant on veut pas
alimenter l'un et l'autre il a beaucoup
qui sont du côté de poutine quant à
l'otan l'otan on se souvient justement
qu'un conflit qui était celui de l'ex
yougoslavie
notamment du kosovo en 1999 avait vu le
temps intervenir sans mandat particulier
on va là tels faits parce qu'il n'y
avait pas la menace du nucléaire est
donc là la nouveauté face est pas
nouveau lumière mais on voit bien que
dans ce conflit saclay brandi il ya les
bruits salué
s'il n'y avait pas eu le nucléaire en
russie il y aurait eu forcément une
intervention de l'otan donc ça veut dire
je suis assez d'accord avec vous quand
il faut revoir les alliances mais en
même temps la permanence de ce qu'est la
menace nucléaire fait que on a quand
même peu de marge de manoeuvre
la dernière question c'était sûr faut-il
lire avec non non il faut toujours
envisager regarder quand même les
conflits en europe quand ça a été de la
répression c'était l'allemagne de l'est
153 la hongrie en 1956 l'explication
tient en 68 répression ça a été la
guerre en serbie contre un nationalisme
après on peut juger l'otan et
aujourd'hui c'est un nationalisme au
pouvoir lors je vais pas paraphraser
mitterrand parce que lui il savait de
quoi il parlait en étau en étant avec
ses accointances avec le régime de vichy
me lisez le nationalisme c'est la guerre
oui oui c'est vrai il ne faut pas se
résoudre à ce qu'un type comme poutine
d'abord
advitam eternam au pouvoir et de deux
piliers justement ces espèces d'accès
comme le covin qui est des accès de
guerre blaise east belliqueux dont il
faudrait s'acclimater et on dirait bon
pas tout ça n'est pas grave parce que
sur la longueur on était tombé oui mais
gauthier fait encore faut-il être
capable de l'en empêcher oui bien sûr je
suis d'accord mais vous voyez le
résultat aujourd'hui lui qui en paie ski
personne c'est pas parce qu'on a guère
on y emmène aujourd'hui elle a lieu les
ukrainiens souffrent et nous sommes
spectateurs et c'est pas parce qu'on ne
peut pas empêcher aujourd'hui il faut
considérer que ce sera demain la même
chose c'est toujours agir maintenant et
bien sûr on est bien d'accord on nous
sommes sous la menace d'une guerre à
tout moment dans l'espace européen
pensez-vous dans l'union européenne à
nous
la présence de l'otan justement et et de
l'armé nucléaire en france nous en
prémunir nous sommes sous la menace bien
sûr et je pense que justement ce qui a
fait que cette guerre a fait tout d'un
coup fait peur à tout le monde une fois
de plus j'ai couvert d'autres guerres
précédemment dans d'autres pays je n'ai
jamais ressenti auprès de mes
concitoyens une aussi grande peur que
depuis le 24 février 2022 ça veut bien
dire
qu' il y ait cette menace est ressenti
et les ressentis presque physiquement
parce qu'il ya cette proximité
géographique l'ukraine ce n'est pas loin
parce que les ukrainiens sont venus
jusqu'à nous parce que la guerre dure
depuis des mois et des mois parce qu'on
en parle tout le temps parce que
aujourd'hui justement avec la façon dont
fonctionnent les médias et ça c'est une
cette façon ne sera jamais modifié on ne
retournera jamais en arrière on sait
tous à chaque instant on sait quel
missile ton ou moi les guerres que j'ai
couverte en irak en si on avait dit ça
on ne savait pas ça donc du coup on
n'avait pas la même couverture donc du
coup on n'avait pas la même empathie
donc du coup on n'avait pas la même peur
la même réflexion donc on est sous une
menace bien sûr et ce sont nos
dirigeants
d'essayer d'avoir une réflexion pour que
nous nous en sortions sans que son
n'aboutisse à la troisième guerre
mondiale
malheureusement pour l'été sur ces mots
at il conclu je suis d'accord bécane
pour le coup mais je pense que la peur
notre peur est à la mesure de notre
ignorance pendant des décennies et
notamment pendant les 22 années de règne
de vladimir poutine n'a pas voulu voir
quel était le personnage entre en
intervalles ça c'est certain mais pas
que sur la demie retour est aveugle ou
ajouts en justice parce que ça que vous
avez écrit sur vladimir poutine et vous
allez retirer depuis un moment déjà
merci beaucoup à niveau on vous retrouve
à la rentrée puisque plus loin va
marquer une pause à la fin de cette
semaine et que nous retrouvons
évidemment nos habitués à la rentrée
avec vous évidemment gauthier qui
continue la semaine avec nous restez sur
france 24 on se retrouve dans trois
minutes pour un nouveau journal